Don't you love your country?
You can't spell America without Erica.
Mmm.
Can I try the peppermint stick?
Haven't you already tried
the peppermint stick?
Yes and I'd like to try it again.
[Bell ringing]
I'd like to try the peanut butter
chocolate swirl, please.
Ahoy! all hands on deck. Ahoy!
[Bell ringing]
Hmm.
-Yeah, I don't know.
-You don't know if you can fit?
Oh, I can fit.
I just don't know if I want to.
Are you claustrophobic
[snickers] I don't have phobias.
-Okay, well what's the problem?
-The problem is,
I still haven't heard what's in this
for Erica.
[nautical tune playing]
More fudge please.
Go on.
Do this for America... Erica.
Ooh!
I just got the chills.
Oh, yeah, from this float,
not your speech.
All right, nerds.
I'm there.
Do you-- Do you see anything?
-Booby traps?
-If I could see them,
they'd be pretty shit traps,
-wouldn't they?
-Thank you for that.
[yells]
We're stuck in here.
Yeah.
Just so you nerds are aware.
I'm supposed to be
spending the night at Tina's
and Tina always covers for me
but if I'm not back for
Uncle Jack's party tomorrow
and my mum finds out
you three are responsible.
She's going to hunt
you down one by one and
Hey! Hey! Be careful, careful, careful!
We don't even know what that is
Exactly. It could be useful.
Useful how?
We could survive here a long time
without food,
But if the human body doesn't
get water, It will die.
I hate to break it to you,
But this is not water.
No, but it's a liquid,
and if it comes down to
me drinking that shit
or dying of thirst
I drink.
You're all so nerdy it makes me physically ill.
Okay, it's official I'm never having kids.
What are we doing here?
We're laying low,
cooling off.
like Oswald.
Oswald was found in a
theatre and shot to death.
Shh!
-Shh!
Erica?
What the hell is that?
A deadly weapon,
could be useful.
For what?
What do you think?
Taking down commie's,
saving your friends.
What? You're just
going to waltz in there
like it's commie
Disneyland or something?
I'm sorry who are you?
Erica Sinclair.
Who are you?
Murray... Bauman.
I'm sorry, why is this
four-year-old speaking to me?
Uh, I'm ten you bald bastard!
Erica!